I'm gonna zoom in on the sign and then
you're gonna walk from their entrance
right next to me right here let's go
look cool right yeah
hey there I'm Aria and I'm fascinated by
love in particular the idea of a Vegas
wedding and I figured what better way to
get the full experience than to marry a
stranger here in 24 hours hey hey are ya
to begin this adventure I get a quick
tour of the chapel I'll be getting
married in tomorrow where you will be
standing here tomorrow is right here
right here
you get everything all in one that's the
reason why people do it here it's
incredible value tons of fun
tons of energy that's why people come
here and do it in Vegas do you think
I'll be able to find someone oh for sure
yeah
for sure you're in Vegas myth despite
Mike's confidence in me not only do I
have to find someone to marry in less
than 24 hours but there's another
obstacle I have to tackle so obvious I
don't want to actually get married I'm
not that crazy I'm crazy just not that
crazy and so basically I need to find
someone to marry in a way that meets the
terms for an annulment so I've done my
research and from I understand there are
several ways you can get an annulment
here in the state of Nevada and one that
jumps out at me is here it says their
grounds for annulment include if you or
your spouse was married to someone else
at the time of your marriage so I'm
thinking if I marry someone who's
already married I can get married
without it actually County has a real
marriage
all right right if I find someone who is
legally married
if I marry them the marriage actually
won't count so I know Mandy is there a
chance you're married and free tomorrow
from 2:00 to 3:00 oh I'm not crazy
you're looking at me like a crazy ride
do you think this is crazy Ryan do you
think I'm crazy Ysidro I'm not crazy
after I failed to convince myself of my
sanity I begin my hunt to find a married
woman to marry me I've run every
Facebook group I can for parents married
couples here in Las Vegas I've also hit
up Craigslist I'm looking at meetup
groups and just hopefully at least one
person hopefully one person hopefully
one person gets back to me most likely
I'm just gonna get bad a bunch of
Facebook groups but oh well not wanting
to call it a night just yet I decided to
try our luck after dinner with a quick
pit stop unfortunately since it's a
weeknight I'm only able to find a couple
of people to chat with I'm hoping to get
married tomorrow really yes thank you
IIIi don't have anyone marry yet I'm
wondering if either of you are married
and free tomorrow from 2 to 3 p.m. to
marry me despite striking out I actually
get some helpful perspectives I think
people are drawn to Vegas weddings for
the immediate gratification this further
moment happening right now the weddings
for you and other person is not for
everybody else you know and that's a
very intimate
time and I just loved idea that you know
you can actually be able to do it in
such a spontaneous and still like really
cool way it is truly the most humbling
and exciting experience feel just to run
off with that person you know or the few
people that mean the most to your life
and just share those moments with each
other we're here on the strip right now
it is 9:00 a.m. we're just hours away
from the wedding trying to find someone
to marry it's hectic a lot of those
people are going by it's it's it's
turning to a bit of a struggle excuse me
excuse me are either of you married and
I'm wondering are you both married yeah
you both married 20 years
fantastic seven years perfect I'm just
wondering if you two are married and if
one of you is free to get married to me
today between 2:00 and 3:00 p.m.
you know I married alright well that
won't work no thank you very much
appreciate with the clock running out I
grow increasingly frustrated I'm just
about ready to give up when suddenly
okay so we actually just got a response
on one of the Facebook groups I posted
in last night
this guy Omar responded to it and says
he's not in Vegas but would love to
share and tag this woman named Nick [ __ ]
Nick he corresponded and says that she'd
love to meet with us she gives an email
address and says please feel free to
contact me with any other info needed hi
this is Nick Iike oh is it like Nick
Hika Nike oh hi Nike oh thank you so
much for sending in that message so from
what I understand you are married is
that correct right fantastic and you
would be free to come marry me today at
between 2:00 and 3:00 p.m. I'm so happy
about this thank you so much you're
you're definitely married though thank
you we'll see you soon bye bye
getting married there's a lot in Vegas
this is love we meet up with nykeya and
her wife back at the chapel who both
turned out to be a lot of fun I'm gonna
lesbian marriage so if I get the
opportunity to marry one hot straight
guy why not a very sweet
nykeya and Monica are newlyweds
themselves and seem to have a great
relationship I mean just the thought of
being able to express and show love in
its natural form is just awesome so I
thought it would be a great opportunity
to just share that experience something
that we both shared that we want to
share
it's a beautiful thing so with an hour
to spare I'm thrilled that we somehow
managed to pull it off I'm also
particularly happy that I don't have to
cancel on the actors I hired to be
wedding guests including those playing
the parts of my parents it's still
surreal to me but I'm so happy that you
found your partner I mean I've got mine
I'm so glad you're both still alive to
be here yes so much finally after a
crazy 24 hours the wedding begins all
their pools run
[Music]
all right I want to look at your
beautiful bride and repeat after me I
will never leave you baby I will never
leave you baby never leave you never
leave you at the Heartbreak Hotel
at the Heartbreak Hotel I will never
ever leave you I will never ever leave
you until after this ceremony now by the
power vested in me anastasia Nevada
I will now pronounce you husband and
wife
you may now seal your love with a kiss
[Applause]
the ceremony takes less than 15 minutes
but it's ridiculously fun and it's
certainly an experience I will never
forget but I think what I learned most
is that it doesn't really matter where
you get married you can have a huge
wedding or a small one but ultimately
all that actually matters is that you're
standing there
face-to-face hand-in-hand with the
person you love so if anyone out there
is planning on getting married maybe
consider a wedding like this although
ideally you're marrying someone who
doesn't already have a spouse one time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm really happy right now
[Music]